and now I'd like to introduce you to our
featured presenter today professor zhu
zhu li onabi hilda's li so julia is a
professor of the practice and the
executive director of Stanford's changed
leadership for sustainability program
her research and teaching focuses on
business strategies leadership
approaches and cross sector partnerships
that spur global development and align
systems with the goal of
intergenerational well-being pride or
served as the executive director of the
Lemelson foundation the director of
World Wildlife fund's Pacific marine
office and the CEO of Washington step
julia holds a BA from Stanford
University and a master's in philosophy
from the University of Sussex where she
was recognized as a distinguished young
global leader by the World Economic
Forum in 2010 and with that let us turn
it over to Julia hello and thank you for
joining us really thrilled to have all
of you here today and to talk about such
an important topic so important in our
time and really looking forward to the
Q&A at the end as well to hear some of
the perspectives all of you have
regarding this shift we're starting to
see in business as it becomes more and
more than norm to embrace sustainability
so today we're going to organize our
conversation around three core themes
there we go okay so first why have are
we seeing the shift in approach why are
we seeing more and more businesses and
organizations in general embracing
sustainability second what strategic
changes are organizations making as they
embrace this change and finally how are
they actually implementing these changes
so we're going to look a little bit at
the why and the what and the how
throughout the hour first let me share a
perspective as we get into the why here
you know what is causing organizations
to increasingly embraced sustainability
and Po Pullman former CEO of Unilever
where he was for a decade summarizes an
insight that is driving this shift and
fundamentally he says we must develop a
business model aimed at contributing to
society in an environment instead of
taking from them and it's not just
Unilever that has this insight of course
we're seeing
and businesses of all varieties from
small companies to transnationals like
Unilever embracing sustainability and
not simply as we've seen in the past as
an effort to comply with regulations or
to be charitable through corporate
social responsibility initiatives but
really embracing sustainability is core
strategy putting sustainability at the
heart of a company's business model so
let's step back a little bit and ask
ourselves why are businesses doing this
why is this happening and why is it
happening now as we've all experienced
firsthand and our personal lives and in
our work we are increasingly operating
in an environment characterized by
volatility uncertainty complexity and
ambiguity and Luca is actually a term
that was coined by the US Army War
College to describe the geopolitical
context resulting from the end of the
Cold War but more recently it is now
used widely in business to describe a
complexity of the operating environment
that we're in so we could of course
devote an entire course to the causes of
Luca world but in a nutshell Luca world
results from the fundamentally dynamic
and nonlinear interactions between human
beings and the natural environment so as
we're going about our business we are
working and living in able natural
environment and there are all sorts of
feedbacks
and interactions that are so complex and
nonlinear that it leads to a lot of this
volatility and complexity that we're
seeing and from the human side we're
looking at you know the combination of
technology breakthroughs across a wide
variety fields that have impact
population growth of course depletion of
Natural Resources and climate change and
also an increasing demand by the public
for transparency and accountability in
business so all of this is feeding into
businesses shifting their approach to
one where sustainability is more
embraced and what we're starting to see
is that because of the volatility
companies are experiencing they've begun
to look outward in an effort to
understand the sources of disruption
they face and to determine how best to
navigate them so
this has led many institutions to take
more of a systems approach recognizing
their fundamental interconnectedness to
the world around them and see not only
the extent to which they are impacted by
outside forces but becoming more and
more aware of the breadth and depth of
their own impact on society in the
natural environment back to Paul Coleman
at Unilever he talks about the need for
companies to see themselves as part of
an interconnected web linking multiple
players and taking a systems perspective
as companies do this it naturally
deepens the responsibility companies
feel and organizations feel towards
diverse stakeholders as they become more
aware and also it becomes clear that
without engagement and collaboration
with stakeholders a lot of these
challenges cannot be addressed these
things are fueling a second shift which
is the integration of sustainability
into core strategy as a means to
mitigate risk that they're facing but
also to strengthen their resilience in
the face of Luca world and finally to
also capture value and see the
opportunities for creating new value by
focusing on sustainability so before we
go into more detail I want to step back
and just say a few words about
sustainability because it is a term that
is often understood differently by
different people it seems to invoke
disparate reactions from different
communities and I think a starting place
for thinking about sustainability is the
framing Jane Jacobs offers when she
reminds us that the economy is a wholly
owned subsidiary of the environment and
not the other way around we really can't
have an economy without an environment
all of the inputs come from our
environment yet sustainability is really
not an environmental term or a green
concept as we've tended to think of it
in the past in fact it's a very human
concept sustainability is about building
a society that provides for the
long-term well-being of its people and
this requires us to recognize our
fundamental dependence on the natural
world and to know that we must generate
social economic and environmental
in order to thrive so we like to use the
term intergenerational well-being to
describe sustainability because we're
talking about the well-being of all
people not just a privileged few and
we're talking about building a society
where we can provide for that well-being
not just today but across generations
the online course and our strategies for
sustainability program includes
extensive interviews with Kate Brandt
Google sustainability officer and Adam
Lowry co-founder of method cleaning
products and ripple foods and what I
wanted to do is just incorporate
throughout this webinar three brief
clips from those interviews that you'll
see in more completion on the online
course to give you a few industry
perspectives people who are grappling
with this in their own companies because
so many of you are doing the same so
let's turn to a brief clip and hear
their perspective on why we're seeing
the shift in business approach business
needs to have a product perspective
around the innovation that it's
providing and at a very basic level
we're living in a time where a lot of
the social contract between business and
societies has broken down and a lot of
that I would argue is because of a hyper
focus on shareholder primacy when you
put shareholders in front of anyone else
and then you know you've got some policy
makers in your back pocket then the
outcome sometimes are things that aren't
good for the population as a whole and
rightfully so people get angry about
that right
what I'm trying to do with my businesses
and what many other people are trying to
do is try to build in enlightened
corporate governance into that model of
innovation so that what gets innovated
is inherently better for society and the
environment as well and if that's a
design exercise and if you can do that
well and then you can grow a business
focusing not just on one thing which is
shareholder return but a broader set of
things which makes managing and leading
a business more complex and a little
harder but if you can do that and do
that well then you're achieving the goal
there is increased motivation for
companies to shift toward sustainability
for a few reasons
I think generally there is now an
expectation that businesses will serve a
social purpose yeah we heard that from
Larry Bank and his shareholder letter
that is a tremendous shift and I think
that's led to you know much more
executive engagement from corporate
leaders and philanthropy and advocating
for social environmental causes and I
think it's led to a lot more activity
within companies of really having very
robust sustainability programs that I
think are really geared towards you know
expectations from customers from
employees and from investors that we're
seeing increasingly that you know you
need to have time-bound goals you need
to be incorporating this into your
operations and increasingly incorporated
into your business strategy and making
it part of how you think about
generating value I think that today's
operating environment is really
requiring businesses to take more of a
systems approach and I think that's both
because we're increasingly facing
greater risks so looking at changing
climate constraints on water constraints
on other natural resources and it
sustainability is a really critical way
to assess those risks to do scenario
planning and to develop new strategies
in the face of a world that's changing
before our eyes equally I think there's
a lot of opportunity you know when we
think about developing or circular
business models where we're designing
waste out of systems that creates
tremendous new opportunities and
opportunities for value Thanks so to
complement their perspectives I want to
just dive in briefly to looking at the
perspective of various stakeholder
groups investors customers and employees
and say you know how are they perceiving
the role of business now are there are
we starting to see shifts in that way
that might also be contributing to the
reason that business is becoming to
embrace sustainability so let's turn
first to investors you heard Kate Brandt
mentioned Larry Fink in 2018 Larry Fink
the CEO of Blackrock the world's largest
investment manager gave a wake-up call
to corporate CEOs when he wrote in his
annual letter to Blackhawks investees
announcing that a company's ability to
manage environmental social and
governance matters demonstrates the
leadership and good governance that is
so essential to sustainable growth which
is why we are in
recently integrating these issues into
our investment process that was that was
a big wake-up call for companies and of
course a lot of companies had already
perceived that shift in in requirement
and recognize the benefits of reporting
on environmental social and governance
issues if we look at the data
eighty-five percent of companies now
produce and share ESG reports with
investors which is up from only twenty
percent in 2011 that's a pretty big
change in a few years and now we've got
more data that demonstrates the positive
ESG performance is correlated with a
lower cost of capital better operational
performance and higher stock price let's
turn to employees and look at what
they're saying so they're pretty similar
pressure on companies younger
generations in particular who make up
the largest population in the workforce
expect businesses to do much more than
turn a profit 83% of Millennials and 80%
of Generation Z
employees believe that business success
should be measured in terms of more than
financial performance Millennials also
believe that employers are generally out
of sync with them when they were asked
to identify the Millennials were asked
to identify three priorities for
business job creation improving society
and enhancing livelihoods and improving
the environment rose to the top while
Millennials say their company's top
three priorities are profit generation
driving efficiency and producing goods
these happen to be the three lowest
priorities on the Millennials list
customers to see business is responsible
for improving society eighty-five
percent of people surveyed across 20
countries hold companies they buy from
accountable for improving their lives
the same level of expectation they have
of government where we traditionally
thought the institutions we
traditionally thought were responsible
for improving our lives so what we're
seeing is as companies start
experiencing more and more of the
realities of Luca world as well as these
heightened expectations of diverse
stakeholders they're increasingly
integrate
new perspectives as they take the
system's approach and look beyond
themselves they're engaging with more
diverse stakeholders that they now see
the deep connection they have with and
ultimately recognizing that pursuing
sustainability can drive innovation and
long-term value creation so here's what
we can hear from an industry perspective
method was a business that I started in
2000 we raised twenty five million
dollars in capital when that business
got sold it multiples in that sale that
were far beyond businesses that had not
build sustainability into their business
models the shareholders the employees
they all made more money financially
because of the business which explicitly
because the business was sustainable not
in spite of it the business has since
grown the business has since sold again
and those shareholders have made more
money because of the type of business
that method is not in spite of it
so it's a very real example of
shareholder value I mean we could just
measure it on shareholder privacy alone
has been higher because the business
focuses on social outcomes in the
environment thank you so much so I just
want to shift now back to Unilever and
and mention that Paul Polman took quite
a similar tack to the one atom Lauer
he's describing when he questioned the
traditional notion that generating
profits must be the primary purpose of
business ultimately the end leading to
science societal benefit rather he
argued that it was the other way around
by focusing first on improving lives and
generating genuinely sustainable
solutions companies would be profitable
over the long term the new operating
system for business he argued would
drive growth through innovations the
bring new sustainability benefits to
consumers and retailers lower cost by
reducing waste and energy use and help
manage supply chain risk by securing
long term sustainable sourcing of
materials and he called for shift info
just from shareholders just like this
share well the primacy Adam Lowry talks
about to all stakeholders he says I
don't think our fiduciary duty is to put
shareholders first I say the opposite
what we firmly believe is that if we
focus our company on improving the lives
of the world citizens and come up with
genuine sustainable solutions we are
more in sync with consumers and society
and ultimately this will result in good
shareholder returns so he's really
flipping our traditional understanding
and and mirroring what we heard from
Millennials which is a lot of companies
just seem to be out of sync with their
priorities Paul Polman is is focusing on
getting in sync so let's turn from the
why our first question in this webinar
to the what what are some of the
concrete changes that organizations are
making as they embrace sustainability
organizations are changing the way they
do business across many areas but I'd
like to highlight three primary ones
here and then provide some examples of
each they're adapting business models
and practices to focus on sustainability
they're innovating to create sustainable
products and brands and they're also
partnering often with competitors to
drive scaled impact alongside method and
Google there are a few but certainly
growing number of companies
experimenting with and adopting circular
economy approaches let's take a brief
look at a couple of examples to
illustrate the potential of circular
models these are just two of many but
let's let's start with Michelin now
Mitchell has transitioned from a product
to a service oriented business model by
leasing rather than selling tires the
company stays engaged with customers
because it has that continuous
engagement with them rather than just
selling a product and saying goodbye and
then can gather customer feedback and
inform product innovation more
efficiently by controlling its product
through leasing rather than selling good
tires can be recovered and released an
end of life cycle tires can be
cycled into playground surfaces or
converted into fuel the company has 97%
recycling rates in the EU and Brazil and
this is something that's much more
possible because it is controlling the
supply by leasing rather than selling
caterpillar has a global network of
remanufacturing facilities and takes
back millions of end-of-life units
that's each year which requires 85 to 95
percent less energy than new production
and which reduces of course waste in the
need for Virgin Resources a growing
number of companies such as Eileen
Fisher a lot of companies you know Warby
Parker Ben & Jerry's Etsy
seventh-generation method you heard
about have become certified benefit
corporations or B corporations as a way
to operate under a legal requirement to
integrate social economic and
environmental values and goals the
corporations are for-profit entities
just like C corporations but they are
required legally to meet the high
standards of verified social and
environmental performance and to
consider the impact of their decisions
on all stakeholder groups not just
shareholders including their workers
customers suppliers community in the
environment there are now 3,000 B
corporations across about 150 industries
and 60 corporations
several multinationals quite interesting
to see including Procter & Gamble
Unilever down on General Mills and
others have recently accelerated their
acquisition of big corporations and they
say they're using these sustainability
innovators these big corporations
integrating them within their own
companies to help accelerate their own
learning on environmental social and
governance issues to figure out how to
drive sustainable product and brand
creation and David Ellis traits the
financial benefits of the B corporation
approach B corporations averaged a 50
percent revenue growth rate during the
2008 financial crisis and a had a higher
revenue growth rate than public firms of
comparable size
throughout the subsequent Great
Recession according to an 2018 study
conducted at Yale University let's hear
a little bit more from from Adam and
Kate so both of the businesses that I've
started met the products and the ripple
foods RP course they're both certified B
courts and benefit corporations both in
Delaware and what's been interesting is
the journey I think with method we we
were one of the founding be corpse back
in 2007 I forget exactly where we were
on the rating scale which goes from 0 to
200 I think we're right around a hundred
or maybe high 9 used to begin with the
business is now 142 and it's I believe
the highest if not well if not it's one
of the highest manufacturing businesses
highest rated P corpse in the world and
a lot of that is a function of some of
the things that we've been able to do as
we've grown the the most shining example
of that would be building a sustainable
manufacturing facility in the inner city
of Chicago to make all of methods
products for in North America this is a
facility that's renewably powered with
utility-scale wind and solar it's water
neutral its land feel free it's got the
largest rooftop greenhouse in the world
growing leafy greens on its roof growing
vegetables in a food desert so really
cool example those are the types of
things that you can do as you start to
achieve some scale and you have a bigger
balance sheet you can do more and more
interesting things and importantly those
are things that are not just done so
that I can sit here and talk about them
those are things that actually lower the
cost structure of the manufacturing of
the business they improve our vacancy
rates and truancy rates on line workers
at the factory there are hard financial
metrics that those sustainability
investments are allowing a method to
enjoy now you know and that's reflected
in a V Clark score and that's that's the
way it should be if you do the right
things it should accrued all three
bottom lines it should get reflected in
how you measure yourself from a social
environmental standpoint so let's shift
now to sustainable products the third
area I mentioned we'd explore companies
are recognizing the growing opportunity
for sustainable product innovation as
consumers increasingly prefer
sustainable options
and consumer demand is also moving as
the population changes to emerging
markets where needs are often related
directly to sustainability access to
water sanitation etc so what we're
starting to see is is companies really
taking off in terms of capturing the
value that's possible through
sustainable product and brand innovation
but also some interesting efforts to
really work collaboratively with
partners on the ground to pair
sustainable products and brands with
campaigns that create positive social
and environmental impact so let's look
at Unilever as an example in India you
the company recognized that cholera
typhoid and skin and eye infections were
the leading causes of child mortality so
it designed it innovated a new product
lifebuoy soap which is a water saving
soap because this happens to be in a
very arid region but also with ten times
the protection against the specific
disease-causing germs that were the ones
causing these these mortal diseases for
for children and then what they did is
after innovating the product they
partnered with local governments NGOs
and a network of 70,000 rural women to
integrate product marketing and
distribution with hand-washing campaigns
reaching millions of households and
dramatically reducing childhood disease
rates Unilever has developed 26 of these
sustainable living brands what they call
their sustainable living brands which
grew 46 percent faster than the rest of
the business and delivered 70% of the
company's overall growth in 2017 now
some challenges are certainly too big
for one company to tackle alone and even
one sector of corporations to tackle
alone really if they require partnership
across civil society government and the
private sector and so what we're
starting to see is more and more
companies recognizing this in forging
alliances often engaging in pre
competitive problem solving to shift
their sectors towards sustainability for
collective
benefit I'll just give a few examples
and these are certainly very complex
systems challenges with no simple
answers but this will give you a sense
of what some companies are doing in
partnership with government and civil
society the consumer goods forum for
example is a network of 400 retailers
and manufacturers across 70 countries
they represent 4 trillion dollars in
combined sales and they're working
together to reach a net zero net
deforestation in their supply chains so
palm oil has been a big issue that many
of you have probably heard about leading
to a lot of deforestation of very
important rainforests in Indonesia the
consumer goods forum and a network of
retailers there are working with
Indonesian government and other
international agencies civil society and
a range of palm oil plantations to try
to remove deforestation out of the
supply chain figure out how else to grow
palm oil that is less less destructive
and because they're there working on
this together no one company necessarily
will lose competitive advantage if they
step up first and say ok we're going to
do this but the other companies operate
business as usual that that first leader
may may lose competitive advantage while
doing this together and making a shared
commitment and working on the challenge
it allows for greater innovation and
also creates more incentive for everyone
to move in the right direction the
Marine Stewardship Council is another
initiative I've worked on the MSC very
intensely about 20 years ago when it was
being launched by Unilever and World
Wildlife Fund and and the vision was
really to create an economic incentive
for sustainable fishing through
certification and eco labeling of
well-managed fisheries so that products
from those fisheries would have chain of
custody verification end up in our
restaurants or a grocery stores and be
marked with the Eco label you see there
to indicate to all of us that they came
from sustainable sources and many of you
probably know the state of our oceans is
dire global fisheries are have been
collapsing worldwide for decades and the
MSC offers a similar opportunity to
bring government business and civil
society together to create an
organization that is driving for
positive change there are currently
about 10% of fisheries worldwide
by Tazz MSC sustainable finally the
sustainable apparel coalition has
created a set of standardized tools to
help companies in the apparel textile
and footwear industry measure
environmental and social impacts across
their supply chains allowing them to
achieve much greater transparency and
address the unsustainable behavior
collectively now as I mentioned none of
these efforts is simple nor is any of
them without unintended consequence and
consequences and trade-offs companies in
the consumer goods forum for example
don't have clear ways to engage the
thousands of smallholder farmers who are
growing oil palms yet without them
deforestation will continue so it's
really an effort that is very complex
and certainly has not yet reached scale
in terms of success and none of these
three but it is an Avenue through which
change can happen and in which systems
change can happen and we don't really
think there's any other way to do it
it's just important to acknowledge how
complex and challenging it is so let's
shift now to a bit of a how we've talked
about why businesses are shifting their
approach or talki
we've talked a bit about some of the
strategic changes organizations are
making you know what exactly are they
doing when they embrace sustainability
but also it's really important thing
about how our organization is going
about this internally how are they
implementing these changes what barriers
are they coming up against as they try
to make this shift so let's take a look
inside Unilever to explore this in 2010
Unilever launched a 10-year sustainable
living plan or SLP covering all aspects
of its business incorporating all brands
and divisions in every country where it
works an SLP outlined three ten-year
goals aligned with its purpose to make
sustainable living commonplace so at
that time in 2010 Unilever revisited its
purpose and really focusing on you know
our purpose as an organization is to
make sustainable living commonplace and
so they framed these three big ten-year
goals as part of the sustainable living
plan
they said they first want to help more
than 1 billion people improve their
health and well-being we have that
briefcase of the lifebuoy soap as an
example they said they want to have the
environmental footprint of Unilever
products and third they want to source
100% of their agricultural raw materials
sustainably and back to the oil palm
growers I mentioned enhance the
livelihoods of millions of people across
the value chain
you know if how do you really take
responsibility at that level for your
entire value chain all the way down to
the growers so they also have taken this
very seriously in terms of establishing
targets and sub goals under each of
these major goals so for example under
health and hygiene or under health and
well-being they've established goals
around health and hygiene and improving
nutrition under reducing environmental
impact they've set goals and targets
around greenhouse gases water use waste
and packaging and in a sustainable
sourcing and then finally under
enhancing livelihoods
they've set goals and targets internal
terms of fairness in the workplace
opportunities for women and inclusive
business progress against the targets is
measured and reported in Unilever annual
report and accounts to shareholders so
they've been very transparent about both
the goal-setting and the metrics and
targets they're using but also on
reporting on an annual basis in public
forum how they're doing so in order to
do the work and this goes back to the
internal work I talked about in
introducing this section of the webinar
in order to align the company behind the
sustainable living plan
Unilever needed to revisit its internal
systems and processes and reorient
corporate behavior look for where things
were aligned with this goal and look at
where they have processes or systems
that worked against the goals they
stated and figure out what to do about
it so for example Unilever has tied
since it launched SLP Tiger Mew
narration and performance evaluations to
achieving the objectives of the
sustainable living plan it's
moved incentives for short-term profit
maximization by deciding not to publish
quarterly reports are very few publicly
traded companies have made that decision
but there's actually recent data that
demonstrates that those companies that
have actually have better performance
because they aren't driven by decision
making for short-term short-term results
to report to shareholders they also
established two board committees whose
sole responsibility is to provide
top-down oversight on the implementation
of the sustainable living plan and also
all internal and external communications
and Human Resources activities include
SLP making sure that across this massive
corporation all the employees are
hearing about this priority and feeling
a part of it perhaps most importantly
the company supports ongoing learning
and adaptation by engaging employees
it's one thing to learn about it through
communications but it's another thing to
be engaged as an employee as a manager
as a supply chain partner in the process
of designing and implementing practices
that support the SLP so for example
employees work directly on the company's
global wellness efforts such as the Dove
soap self-esteem project or the help of
child reach 5 campaign deepening their
commitment to the sustainable living
plan and deepening their understanding
Unilever managers also work across the
organization and in partnership with
suppliers and distributors to conduct
life cycle assessments of their product
lines so that they can evaluate social
and environmental impacts and determine
changes that need to be made so what
about progress it's one thing to set
goals and targets and it all looks great
but actually how is Unilever doing it's
actually on track to meet around 80% of
its sustainable living plan commitments
across its three major goals by 2020 by
the end of 2017
Unilever had reached 601 million people
through its programs on hand-washing
sanitation oral health self-esteem and
safe drinking water against the target
of 1 billion it had reduced its waste by
29 percent against
target of 50% source 56% of its products
sustainably as verified by third-party
certifiers I guess his target of 100%
and finally it had exceeded its target
to engage at least 500,000 smallholder
farmers in its supply network to improve
their agricultural practices reaching
actually seven hundred and sixteen
thousand farmers so interestingly rather
than suffering from this new business
approach much as Adam Lowry said
Unilever has continued to perform well
Unilever share prices outperformed the
year on X 100 and the footsie 100
indices consistently over the past nine
years and just stepping back Unilever
offers one perspective on how to create
a business model focused on
sustainability by defining new goals and
metrics innovating sustainable products
and brands and aligning its internal
systems and processes to support this
new business model maybe your
organization is quite different but what
would long-term business goals focus on
sustainability look like for you what
does sustainability mean in your context
and where to sustainability offer
opportunities for growth or risk
mitigation value creation how much some
of you believers changes in internal
practices be relevant and doable in the
context of your organization so stepping
back we began with these three core
questions for the webinar you know why
are we starting to see this shift in
approach where businesses are really
starting to pursue an embrace
sustainability what are some of the
strategic changes organizations are
making there are obviously a multitude
we looked at a few and how are they
going about implementing these changes
what are sort of the nuts and bolts of
actually trying to do this in context
and and what we saw is you know it for
the first question were we've got
businesses responding to the reality of
Luca world of changing stakeholder
expectations definitely heightened
expectations of the role of business and
improving lives in solving social
challenges in tackling 21st century
global global challenges but also the
sustainability it has a real role to
play in helping businesses mitigate risk
lower costs and dry growth under the
second we looked at some new business
practices including circular economy
pursuing B corporation status to
sustainable products and sector white
partnerships and then we looked and how
Unilever in particular is aligning goals
processes and incentives to really
support support its its objectives
around sustainability to really walk the
talk internally to make it possible to
make progress against those goals and so
just here at the end before we move to
Q&A I want to just step back and and
look at these broader shifts we are
seeing in society with respect to
business what we talked about today is
part of a larger evolution that's been
going on for decades where we're seeing
companies move from this focus on
compliance and corporate social
responsibility to one where
sustainability is actually a strategy
it's not just a charitable act or
something we've got to do to comply with
regulations it's actually a strategy for
doing well and as we heard from many
Adam Lowry and Paul Coleman and others
this shift from focusing on shareholder
privacy to want to really seeing the
whole network of stakeholders companies
are connected to and impacting and being
impacted by and then also short term
profit moving more towards long term
value creation how do we endure over the
long term generate value have relevance
live up to the responsibility that we
have is business in this changing world
that is so volatile and ambiguous and
complex and and finally how do we start
thinking now about not just company
leadership being a great leader as a
company in your in your sector but also
leading your sector through global
partnerships how do we how we move full
sectors you know to better practice and
actually partner with some of our
competitors to make that happen and that
leads to the final point which is rather
than competitiveness you know being
supreme we're starting to see a real
recognition that the collaboration is
key and just to close I think
you know I want to share the message
that I think in order for business to
really fully capitalize on the
opportunities that sustainability
presents and to play the leading role it
must in tackling 21st century global
challenges these shifts that we
described today that really aren't as
mainstream as we'd like them to be
really need to become universal cultural
norms simply the way things are done in
the 21st century and all of you
listening today thank you for your time
I'm really looking forward to your
questions but you have a really
important role to play in this wherever
you are in your organization whatever
position you can start by asking curious
questions you can start by taking a
systems perspective and being sure
others around you are seeing the way in
which your organization is so
fundamentally connected to other
stakeholders and the natural environment
the social and cultural and historic
context and you can start demonstrating
opportunity through cost-saving measures
that you might identify within your
units or incredibly great value creation
opportunities through through new
product design that's actually really
needing a social or environmental need
that has broader value so look forward
to hearing your questions and thanks so
much for your attention okay great so
now we'll move on to answering your
questions so clearly you know we have an
audience that is really experienced and
knowledgeable about the topic what
you've presented really resonated what
you know their thoughts and your views
on sustainability and corporate strategy
and we've done you know a few questions
really around kind of the specifics of
implementation you know the challenges
to barriers and all of that so one of
the questions that we got from
participants is that you know this line
of thinking is really great for
companies engage in manufacturing you
know resources and traditional
industries are there any examples and
you know are there any ways as to how a
company that's in a service industry can
kind of engage and help out with this
initiative you know for example a
company that's in financial services and
business services how can they
contribute to this effort you know a
great question and certainly I would
argue that it is universally relevant
but certainly needs to be interpreted
and manifested differently depending on
what kind of company or sector or
industry you're in
so absolutely great
question I think Google we didn't hear
as much from Kate as you will in the
online course in my short clips but she
talks a lot about their emphasis and you
know using Google advantage where they
have you know incredible advantage in AI
and machine learning and cloud computing
and pulled those together to generate
incredible cost savings billions of
dollars in the heating and cooling of
their the cooling in particular of their
data centers and so it really you've got
a sit where you're where you are at
Google also you know it's not just cost
savings from a sustainability standpoint
they focus there first and you know
focusing on using again having purely
renewable energy sources their company
but they also move towards societal
benefit you know how can we actually use
our tools to generate benefit for
society so they've actually innovated
this interesting tool called global
fishing watch where they've taken their
GPS capacity combined it with machine
learning with an algorithm that would
help them identify getting data using
you know just getting masses of data
from around the world on boats out on
the ocean and then being able to
identify which boats are actually
fishing boats versus cargo vessels etc
and then being able to see where fishing
boats are actually actively fishing and
if in fact they're fishing illegally
helping governments helping empower
governments to really protect their
fisheries more effectively so it depends
what industry you're in and how you can
combine your talents and your skills and
your advantages and your tech know-how
to to find the right solutions that work
for your company I think related to the
service question in particular I mean
Michelin is an interesting example where
it was a product driven company and
Phillips's shifted to from selling light
lighting services from fishing to prop
from products to selling light as a
service and michelin leasing tires so
that they're controlling that that that
product so a lot of companies are
shifting to from product to service
models and i think there are ways in
which any company can can make that
shift great so the simple question that
we have is you know as a lot more
companies are paying more
attention to this topic - reporting
they're redesigning products you know
their branding is more aligned with the
sustainability message overall there was
also kind of criticism that comes up you
know where people are mentioning we're
accusing companies of greenwashing you
know their practices their products and
etc so you know how can we hold
corporations accountable and you know as
consumers or as civil society what are
some of the metrics and things that we
can look for to really identify whether
a company is simply quote-unquote
greenwashing or are they actually you
know dedicated to this effort
that's a great question it's a huge
challenge we faced it early on with the
Marine Stewardship Council as soon as we
launched the Marine Stewardship Council
which you know we took a lot of time to
develop the global standard for
sustainable fishing it was based on the
UN FAO code of conduct which had existed
for many years it was a very high
standard and scientifically validated in
terms of okay this is really a good
definition of a well managed fishery
well as the MSC label gained traction a
number of industry labels came up where
industry then created its own label for
sustainable fishing and put that on on
products and so it really took education
of consumers and I think that's what it
is it's education of consumers it's
testing these different labels and
really getting the truth about what what
is behind the label what does it really
mean and and that is yes as the person
who asked the question acknowledges it's
it's very complex I one thing that was
really important for the Marine
Stewardship Council is to have the World
Wildlife Fund
you know WWF Panda logo alongside
Unilever when the organization first
launched because it gave credibility and
it held the standard to a very high
level and and then once the tent widened
and many many more NGOs became involved
those NGOs made sure that that standard
stayed high and appropriate and many
times push the embassy saying the
standard wasn't high enough and a
fishery that got certified shouldn't
have been certified and challenged them
so this is the the complexity of the
work but but it needs to be done and I
think you know new technology offers
some benefit I think we will be able to
trace chain-of-custody more easily now
with blockchain and with other
technologies that will help us ensure
that we know about the products that
we're buying and we know more about them
but yes great great question so another
question is that you know our
participants participants come from a
variety of different companies you know
from different industries and that
different scales so a lot of times you
know the companies that are getting the
most exposure through these initiatives
are the large corporations you know
these are multinational corporations
these are very big companies that have
we to do many different industries and
products so how can we get smaller or
medium-sized businesses to be more
engaged or join these initiatives led by
these larger corporations and how can
you know small and medium businesses
contribute to this effort
so when you say join these initiatives
whether you were affirmed
so for example with you know the
consumer that the forms that you've
talked about you know with MSC you know
a lot of times the companies that are
represented and these initiatives are
large multinational corporations so how
can small and medium-sized businesses
also participate well I think it's
absolutely essential that they do
because the the sector is complex and
you know while there is a lot of
consolidation and a lot of control and
market share within the larger companies
the smaller companies are essential and
play a vital role and in fact in the
case of the oil palm example it really
is you know one of the challenges is
what do you do with thousands and
thousands of farmers who don't have a
clear alternative and is Unilever you're
gonna take care and make sure that their
farming practices are sustainable and
their livelihoods are secured because if
not they have only one way to support
themselves which is to continue to cut
the forests and and grow either food or
oil comfort for engaging the cash
economy so it is absolutely essential
that that all scales are engaged and I
think you know some smaller companies
can play a leadership role I think about
a sustainable harvest coffee company and
they you know they're a small operator
within the huge coffee relatively
consolidated coffee industry and they
said we're gonna have a different model
we're gonna have a relationship coffee
models which is basically you know we're
gonna take the linear supply chain and
make it circular and we are going to
have every grower that we work with part
of a team that is connected to Roasters
and bankers and
retailers so that everybody in the
supply chain knows what the reality of
doing business is like for each
stakeholder group in the supply chain
and they have built that model they have
let's talk coffee events that they host
and they innovated every year in a
coffee growing country and now all the
big players are coming McDonald's is
coming you know Walmart's coming they
want to understand and and sustainable
harvest created that platform as a very
small company that said you know we're a
big corporation we have a different
business model we put 50% of profit back
into farmer training and we believe in
transparency they will not do business
with anyone unless every transaction in
the entire supply chain is transparent
so from farmer to roaster and retailer
every transaction is transparent and and
that's allowed them to build these
trusting relationships and shift the way
business is done for this segment of the
coffee industry so small companies can
play a very disruptive and positive role
great so we're getting really close to
our right now we have time for one last
question so um this question
specifically concerns kind of your
experience your perspective so Julie
worked with you know a lot of different
sectors you've worked on partnerships
between government and and business and
industry with companies of different
size so do you see you know certain
business sectors or certain industries
be more receptive to this change than
others and conversely you know which
industries or which sectors are you
seeing the greatest resistance that's a
great question you know I think what is
interesting is to see how different
issues engaged different stakeholders
and and how that happens I mean is it
because you get a Greenpeace campaign
and you're forced to deal with the palm
oil challenge which was was the case for
Nestle and Unilever when they launched a
video or is it that you know you have an
enlightened leader who really wants to
take responsibility and has insight into
some of the impacts that companies
having or a combination I think about a
lot of the chemical companies and things
who are starting to get more and more
engaged because of the plastics issue so
maybe some traditional industries we
thought would
necessarily gave so much in this issue
are really recognizing as we look at our
oceans and they have become filled with
with plastic including micro plastics
the average seafood consumer has
consumes about 11,000 particles of micro
plastics per year so it's not just the
plastic we can see in the ocean and we
know that we're dumping into the ocean
but it's now all of the micro plastics
that are there and so companies are
starting to recognize responsibility and
I'm working right now on an ocean
plastics initiative to really say how do
we get all of these global actors from
throughout the supply chain engaged in
this from the chemical companies to the
recycling infrastructure globally across
nations so I think really it depends how
you look at the challenge but but
everybody everybody has a stake and
everybody's connected to the to the
problem of the solutions so I think it's
a matter of you know what incites the
initial initial engagement great so we
are on top of the hour right now and
we're gonna have to wrap up the Q&A
session so again thank you very much
Julia today for sharing your knowledge
with our participants for those of you
who have indicated an interest in the
program I'll team will definitely be
reaching out with more information if
you have any pressing questions for
Julia or about the program feel free to
reach out to our team as well so as a
final reminder you know the recording of
this webinar will be emailed to you
within a week and you can always visit
us at global impact at stanford.edu
so thank you all for joining us today
and have a great rest of your week
you